so curtis what brought you to story expo
2014. a friend of mine
did it before the expo before and uh
i've been to
two three other pitchfests and he said
this will be different and he's right
it's been different so far
and you flew out from flew out from
south carolina
and uh you know i maintain a place here
only because if a meeting happens that i
need to go to
i can just hop on the plane and have a
place here
uh and that's happened quite a few times
but oh it has yeah and and so do you
drop everything and
i drop everything uh i teach so i have
an assistant i take over my class and
hop on a plane so
what do you teach criminal justice okay
criminal justice and uh yeah it's it's
you know law enforcement
retired so
i went to get my little certificate and
felt like it'd be a great thing to do so
love it love it
so the story that you came to pitch
today how long have you been working on
this idea i started i wrote a book and
it came out in one called juvenile
justice 101 and
toured for a year on the book and i
really wrote that book just for people
in the industry that
in my field
because
you know dealing with juvenile crimes a
lot different than dealing with adult
crime uh you arrest a kid
it's different so
it ended up being a novel that touched a
whole bunch of other people besides
workers in the juvenile world
and so uh
went to long beach to speak at a
conference and then this producer asked
me to write a screenplay and send it to
her and i did
and they ended up optioning the
screenplay
nothing became of that which is why i'm
here because i redid everything and
at risk is what it's called now so
how many times have you rewritten this
i've probably written this one maybe
seven times
seven times yeah i left out a lot of the
things that uh
you know you're dealing with kids you
know
unlike adults you become closer to these
families because it's not just the kid
you you have detained it's the family
so i lost eight kids during that either
murdered or was murdered
um during my my tenure with the
prosecutor's office so i had to go back
and put some of those things in because
i couldn't really deal with them
they were too fresh
and so that's probably why i yeah seven
now i've rewritten it rewritten it seven
times
wow
and i gotta say that the reason i
actually do this is because i met my
brother when he was 12. never even knew
i had a brother
um
and my dad said hey here's here's your
brother and uh he was already in the
gang
12 years old he ran the whole
neighborhood
he's on trial now for murder he murdered
his girlfriend last year
but
he told me
after he read my book
i dedicated the book to him
and he said you know
you've got to do this show
this is my life
he went to juvenile
detention when he was 13.
he's 33 now
he's been in jail the whole time
so that's why that's my number one
project
right because i want to see a tv series
dedicated to just juvenile crime
the story is just
crazy
so
so that's been the driving force for you
is this this
personal thing and knowing these also
these different people that have since
passed away all right so it's not just
yeah you're hoping to get a deal and why
it's way more than that yeah way more
than that for me uh you know if it were
just to get a deal i would have stopped
a long time ago
uh why because i i feel like uh you know
if it was for the money you know
hollywood's a different animal to deal
with you know and not that i can't take
rejection but usually as my wife tells
me um i don't have patience for that you
know um so someone says no a few times
i'll just say okay i'll do something
else
i don't take it personal but this one uh
i have to stick with uh
my paralegal at the time uh
a year before i left uh liz she said uh
you know there's no way you can stop
this until tv show happens
because we lost a great kid that year
he got out of a gang
we got him into an alternative school he
was literally walking to school that day
and got gunned down
his first day of school
in florence south carolina just outside
of myrtle beach
and that kid for the whole summer did
community service did whatever and he
said mr ray
please keep me in this community service
thing because if i go home to the
neighborhood they're going to get me
so work me during the daytime he begged
he rode his bike five miles just to come
downtown
to work in the uh city center
and uh his first day of school that
killed him
because of something he did
the year prior so so those are the
stories that i uh i have to i have to
keep this going you know um and when i
pitch uh of course i use that
because it's real
um you can't make him up
has anyone ever told you to tone down
the violence because it's oh it's too
much yeah yeah actually you know it's
funny you say that a couple years ago my
manager and i
and my former manager
and uh he said before you go in i got to
tell you something they shot me some
notes
and he said you know
i don't know how to tell you this but
they think it's going to be a black
thing
and uh they think it's too violent we
don't want any gang stuff and all that
and i said well they haven't read my
book you know because in my book i have
people from all walks i had before
columbine i dealt with a kid who
threatened to blow up his school
and he had his family was rich you know
two doctors and he had a lab downstairs
in the basement and he could have done
it
so it's not about just the gangs and
about black kids in the neighborhood
someone said to me
pretty much before that same thing
happened that this needs to be a wire
thing it'll happen you know if it's a
wire thing
and i said you know i'm i'm not in this
to redo the wire or
a black white thing crime reaches across
all colors
nationalities you know
crime has no color
and so when i write i write for everyone
i have kids selling pills in rich
neighborhoods
boxes of pills they have pill parties
their parents drive jags they're doctors
and lawyers
they didn't see it that way so
you know they thought it was gonna be a
black thing
so those are the kind of walls
you run into
but you still keep going still keep
going yeah
there's many reasons many people yeah
many people uh one girl gave me her high
school diploma uh i got her out of an
alternative i got her out of regular
high school and got her into an
alternative school
had no idea that she was graduating
valedictorian
and her mom kept calling me one day and
said hey can you make her graduation she
really wants you there and i said well
sure you know i didn't think anything
about it but when i got there
she started talking about this guy that
she took a knife to school
gorgeous girl green eyes you know really
light skin from her she's mixed you know
and everybody hated her at school the
girls because she was pretty and all the
boys liked her she took a night to
school to protect herself and that's how
i got her
well anyway her name is jonesy and so
joe uh
got up gave her valedictorian speech and
was talking about this guy
and
her mom elbows me and starts smiling
she's talking about you i said what well
i had gotten her into the alternative
school because my high school
girlfriend was the guidance counselor at
that school
i called joey up and she got her in
nobody would take her
and she was a straight a student
so and now she's married with kids and
doing well so so these are the things
that you know i did it so long so i have
probably more stories than most um but
those are the reasons why i got to keep
going you know
yeah so she gave me high school diploma
it's on my wall at home
so yeah
you